字幕志愿者 李宗盛
李宗盛
欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华 我是艾伦
今天反弹第二天
但是开高走的
有一点点 上眼线
留头发了
对啊 留头发你不喜欢
长头发喜欢
长头发会喜欢吗
我是说长发跟短发
谢谢
是那个意思
但今天就昨天有說嘛
那個下降趨勢線嘛
今天有碰到
所以有點流上隱線
但我覺得還有機會
還有機會嗎
但是今天嚴格來說
還是空頭反彈對不對
沒有錯
今天我們晚上就期待一下
看這個Google財報
能不能給一些激情
好 這個雲端伺服器的大廠
Google要來了
希望可不可以不要像台積電
是開完後網上不要貪心
7%就好了好嗎
OK
這樣子的話
明天我們的科技股
應該就還滿有機會的
沒有錯
其實今天晚上還有這個
AMD AI大會
所以看我們一些激情
對於AI相關組裝廠
看我們有一些激情
也給大家一些這個催化劑
好 因為AMD講話
有另外一個人也講話
就是揮答就敢在
AMD開AI大會之前
我先接受採訪
沒有錯
我就趕快講一下
這什麼心態
這競爭心態
就是例如說
如果我們今天吵架了
你就會敢在我之前
去接受媒體採訪嗎
對 可能你要先開記者會
我就搶你一點時間開記者會
那就看誰的料多囉
應該沒有這回事啦
OKOK 這體力滿爛的
我們先來看一下AMD大會
是AMD大會在7月22跟7月23
開始在舊金山舉行
就是今天晚上開始
裡面有關注幾個重點
第一個就是新的一代的處理器
Venus
目前來說採用的就是
台積電2奈米的最新的製程
那可以加速的就是CPU跟AI晶片
間接的傳輸的效率
再來第二個就是MI400系列
那這個東西呢
會有包含450X還有500系列的詳細規格
預期會縮小跟輝打硬體的差距
就是嘴感對手
那不過呢這個重點會擺在
它也有一個機櫃叫做Helios
那這個Helios就會是對標
對標就是那個輝打的GRACE
還有Valubin的這個相關的機櫃
所以它也出
它不只是賣CPU
它也把它整台端出來賣
它也賣機櫃
沒錯 據說這個機櫃
好像會賣得比Rubin還要貴
還要貴 好像貴40%喔
貴滿多的
是不是 很貴
沒錯 因為裡面用到的
就是台積電2奈米
這個Vera呢
VeraRubin是用3奈米
就是它用更貴一點點的
我們等一下會跟大家介紹
也就是說這一個相關的
今天的AMD大會
能不能在這一些東西上
帶給我們相關的
CPU也好
GPU也好
組裝廠也好
老AI或者是AI族群上半遊
看能不能來一些機器
好 而且這個機櫃有人買了
沒錯 微軟買了
微軟已是客戶
微軟果然錢很多 微軟有錢
好 我們來看一下
兩個相關的一些細節的差別
那當然我不是
昨天是曲伯來嘛
理工出身的
昨天講這個專利圖
沒錯 很多人問我們兩個說
有沒有放空 怎麼敢
等一下曲伯反問我們的時候
對 我們都點頭說了解
实际上还要再消化一下
那我们就简单讲一下
它的一些效能
跟里面的一些差别
GPU消耗的功耗比较大的
是这个挥达
这个也是可能AMD
稍微厉害一点的地方
那来说的
整个制程技术的话
我们刚刚提到
2奈米
没错
那台积电这边呢
挥达这边是用3奈米
所以这边确实
有可能就是因为
比较贵的原因
因为它是用最贵的
然后再来的话
软体生态系
就是开放的标准
那挥达者是用
挥达者是用自己的生态系
輝達一直都是自己生態系
沒錯
所以目前看起來
這個我覺得看起來還蠻厲害的
就是真的有可以匹敵的概念
是的
那輝達也是因為知道AMD要開AI大會了
所以昨天先去受採訪
而且後來還跑到德州
去幫偽創站台
沒有錯
所以偽創今天就直接一根掌停板
那我們來看一下
這個輝達就有先講了
它的VARUBIN已經進入了爬坡的階段
量產爬坡
沒錯 供應鏈有350多個工廠
然後有30個國家
有超過300家合作夥伴
那這個台灣大概佔了150
其實也佔了是一個非常大的幅度
所以台灣確實
一樣像這一次主技術有公佈
6月的那個出口的外銷訂單
沒錯 900多億
對 創新高
對 單月新高
連17G的這個上場
所以真的現在就是技術面上的空投
但基本面上是多投
那裡面有一些相關的一些公司
什麼Curve Wave Google
然後Microsoft Oracle
全部都有提到
那另外一個呢
就是它主要還是在講CPU啦
那因為確實嘛
AMD就是CPU大廠
所以呢它這次說了這個
Vera CPU呢
就是要為這個Agentic AI
去做打造的
裡面會有兩倍的
這個單直型的性能
也有三倍的核心的頻寬
那再來呢它會比
競爭對手會有少
40%的記憶體延遲
所以就是它厲害的地方
好 它現在很care這個事情
沒錯 因為記憶體太貴了
是的 能用就用
沒錯
所以呢它這邊有說啊
CPU会影响到AI中心的效率
重点就是它的利用率
如果CPU够好的话
那它的利用率会更好
所以现在为什么CPU在前一阵子
可以有一个大放异彩的股价的表现
就是因为原本可能是1比8
那现在可能要提到1比1
这个就是一个大重点
那重点是之前回答也有说过
它这边呢
自己的CPU
Virard CPU呢
会有一个市场规模
2000亿美元的数字出来
那就是要跟AMD
还有英特尔的核心业务去做抵抗
他也说了他现在呢
已经不是这个卖GPU的公司了
他是AI基础建设的公司
是的
所以呢
回答就先出招了
那再来就是看一下AMD
确实嘛 回答出招
今天伪创确实很强劲嘛
对 那也带动了一些老AI
今天的表现是相对深版的
今天台积电是收叠的喔
对 那也带动了这个AI
有一些这个激情出来
那看AMD今天晚上能不能继续有激情
那我们加油 OK
好 讲完了之后呢
另外一个就是
據傳台積電還沒有回應
這是真實的
所以要先跟大家講清楚
這個是有新聞這樣子講
那台積電說不予置評
好 那有講到什麼
就是講漲價
要漲價了
本來這一次法說
也有很多人事前說
會不會講漲價
可是因為它歷年
都是在第一季的法說
1月法說
才會去提到這件事情
所以呢
我們還是去看一下
明年的Q1
再來去檢視這件事情
因為它確實
打假後面會講到
那確實啊
目前傳出來是
台積電可能在
2027年會漲價10%
確實嘛沒有什麼四五倍
可能也就10%
台電每次都好客氣
對 我們先進製程呢
可能呢以7nm以上的會漲5到10%
但是如果你還用到高效能晶片的呢
會再堆疊10到15%
另外成熟製程呢
也大概最多就是漲10%
所以影響的客戶呢
當然就是這些CSP大廠了
好 另外呢 漲價是為什麼
它漲價不是為了賺更多錢
是因為呢
整個的成本
不管是營運成本
或者是海外擴廠的折旧成本
都帶動了這一個必須要漲價
或者毛利率才可以維持在53%以上
但是漲20%啊
對啊 漲50%啊
漲100%
對啊 漲了嘛
好沒有開玩笑
所以它漲價的原因就是
為了要抵消它可能因為
在海外積極的擴廠而帶動的成本
還有一些原物料的通膨上升的原因
好 那再來呢
目前台積電採取
其實這個魏哲嘉先生
在法術會也有提到
他們不會
他們要跟客戶是共融的
其實這就是台藝店好的地方
共融
他才會綁住
那麼長期的忠實客戶
沒有錯
所以他強調的就是
這是策略導向
不是機會導向
這感覺是在講某個題
什麼什麼題
都是機會導向
沒錯
實機材
也不能這樣講
確實很需要
OK 好
這個是一些
我覺得台面上的一些小激情
那我们来看一下
这个激情带给我们台湾股市呢
是昨天有一个历史单日
最大的涨点
那今天呢有开高
盘中也撑了一阵子
到了尾盘才被卖下来一点点
可是你看
两天
两天就把这个黑K
吃掉
有沒有cover掉啦
很厉害耶
是的
所以呢我要跟大家讲
像我们昨天有来讲嘛
可是我们财富已经不涨这样了
应该是涨这样的
对财富已经回不来了
好
我们来看一下
前低我们说了嘛
昨天有说42,000有手好事
那昨天三天内站回季线好事
所以我们说这边应该是初步
见到指稳的状态
但是指稳呢你要转折呢
我们昨天有画一条下降趋势线
那我们也说嘛
你可以连同月线一起观察
今天反弹到哪里
就是这个月线跟下降趋势线的
压力区
那尾盘就有一些卖下来了
那当然卖下来也不是说
这里就结束了没细唱了
那我会觉得接下来的
这个美国科技股财报
如果有一个比较好的利多
这边还是有机会去向上挑战的
当然我们还是必须先强调
目前这个短线的空方的
这个行情震荡都没有去做转折
对 有指稳
但你要让它整个空方转折
这个高点一定要先过
所以这个是后面这几天
礼拜四礼拜五要特别去观察的
而且礼拜四礼拜五
你也没有来录节目
大家好自为之
不会啦 下礼拜二就见面了
就来检验一下
看有没有出现更好的状况
你看这两天很开心啊
好好的啊 你都顾得好好的啊
希望明天也好好的
因为我觉得明后天很重要
如果这个地方能够站上
至少就会是
如果是涨到这个地方来再走回撤
那我觉得信心会更稳妥
那如果来到这边呢
上去直接没有过
反而是比如说明天
可能我们讲一个比较糟糕的状况
假设它跌破了今天的低点
那还有跌破了接近季线的位置
那可能整理就真的有机会
要回撤前低喔
那前低看能不能重新打第二只脚
第二指角
希望是不要這樣
希望我們就是順順的
好 今天碰壓力嘛 OK
壓力有賣壓 消化一下
今天有好消息
明天直接串高
那我覺得是最好
好啦 因為上禮拜二你來
是一個非常長的下影線
然後伴隨隔天還大漲
對 所以
然後又碰壓力又加了
對啊 要加油喔
貴買了 貴買今天比較強嘛
貴買因為信華連續兩天漲停板
然後有一些什麼
台藥連續兩天漲停板
這就是貴買比較大的權值戶
對 那今天呢
也是一根紅K站回五日均線
那以大盤來講
觀察是月益線跟下降趨勢線
以貴買來講的話
觀察的位置就是這個地方
就是400關卡
因為這個地方是一個大頭部的壓力區
真的 長得好涣散
沒錯
那今天也是稍微碰到就有點上影線
甚至上個禮拜五的黑K的高點
還沒有收不回來
對 盤中這個至少有碰到
雖然收盤價沒有質問
沒有收上去
那目前來說
貴買還是一個空方結構
請大家要記得
我們要至少站回季線
才是最穩妥的
這個一定要記得
目前还是在跌身后的反弹
反弹能不能转折
就看这波能不能弹够强
这是贵买的部分
好 再来我们看到的就是台积电
台积电涨得有点破碎
OK啦 台积电今天跌10块
跌10块是跌80点
那我们刚大盘涨接近600点
所以你看到今天的全值股
应该相对非常强劲
因为台积电如果把台积电扣掉
今天应该要涨到接近700点了
对 所以台积电呢
今天一个开高走低
反而资金去做一个试出
那这个试出流到了就是
隔壁的这一些相关的概念股
那目前来说台积电
我们先做个结论
今天又跌破月线跟这个MH10
但整体来讲的话
目前我觉得都还算是健康
因为就也在季线之上
然后目前也补完空方缺口
所以我觉得都还算可以
即便有回落的过程中
应该都是扛得住
那再来看到的是鸿海
鸿海今天长头发
没错 今天原本盘中一度到赏5%
但后面慢慢的在尾盘
又有一波卖压
被稍微小卖下来
不过呢鸿海今天这根K棒是我们两三周以来的短线新高也突破了一个压力区就是这个箱形的高点那今天还有出一点量我觉得非常不错
那另外一个呢
就是尾盘今天表现整个大盘不是到这么好
很多个股有一些甚至涨停被撬开
所以尾盘跟着一局一到卖压
比较可惜的是
季线原本有站稳
后来没有
那不过没有关系
目前季线还是上弯
所以也不算是压力
那接下来就看一下
OK 这边直稳了
那这边有带动上来
那整个
AI伺服器代工廠
或者说AIPC的品牌厂
那板卡系列
其实今天的表现是还不错的
那看后面有没有机会
去做一个延续啊
能不能去AMD
也再释出一些利多
相关的组装厂
应该就可以持续有一个表现
那另外一个表现过程中
当然嘛 鸿海嘛
所以就会带动大盘
有一个比较成盘的效益
所以希望确实能够
借由这样子的方式啊
让我们大盘的走势
能够越走越稳
好 那这个是今天的
大盘跟全资股
是
好
所以刚刚讲了有一个事情很重要
其实大概在两三周前
爱人有提醒到要避风
避到台速四宝
后来风真的吹过去了
所以大家也可以看到
也因为有这些全值股的撑盘
所以指数看起来不惨
但中小型股跌得很惨
如果现在台积电 鸿海这些等等
它是比较相对抗跌的
风又吹回到他们身上
包括像今天伟创市长停板
有华人勋的加持
那这样的风水轮轮转
就能支撑我们台股在下半场
继续怎么样多头气势能够往上走
这个很重要
所以广告回来
艾伦就会来教大家了
如果钱能够回到这些已经跌出价值来
现在相对甚至是抗跌的老AI的话
该怎么样做选择
待会来跟大家揭晓
好
好 我們今天後面的一些相關的個股介紹
也是圍繞在AMD跟輝達身上
我看這個AMD
它這個型態好厲害喔
是的
它離前高不遠耶
它現在544塊
它很扛啊
你看它這邊也是支撐前提都有收好
對啊
然後碰激線
站在所有均線上耶
對 所以我覺得目前的型態
應該都是相對厲害一點點
那瑞銀有調升上目標價
從670...到了700元
所以今天晚上看一下
有沒有一些亮點出現
那相關的一些整個AMD概念股
其實高度重疊
那我們今天來幫大家介紹的就是
跟AMD第一個有相關
第二個它可能就是台灣的
伺服器代工廠也好
或者是說AIPC品牌廠
或者是板卡廠
那基本上我們今天幫大家介紹這一些
那這一些有一個特點
就是漲跌都很少
這是昨天的
昨天幫大家檢驗了發哥
那今天還有一個續談
不過它也是一個開高走低
沒錯 碰越線
那會不會有點
就是在越線這邊會止步呢
要留意嗎
對 我覺得要留意一下
因為開高走低嘛
當然也還好
有一個多方缺口
所以看有沒有一個下來
有繼續買盤推上去
另外整個ABF
今天是非常強勢的
太離譜了
今天幾乎全部都漲停了
除了緊縮
因為大家是輪流漲停
南電應該也是一馬當先
昨天有提到南電是
這裡面這一波最強勢
形態是最好的
那星星是龍頭
那星星跌升反彈
也很快就漲停了
沒錯 那真頂
終於也有個漲停吧
是
所以今天ABF确实盘面亮点之一
那我们进来看一下
今天盘面的小亮点
为什么说小亮点
因为早盘都很强
但尾盘都有点上影线
除了所长庭的伟创
伟创这个黄远轩
红爸爸亲自站台
美国德州的这个达拉斯
D1的新厂开幕
所以就迎来一根大红K
那他说台湾已经摆脱了
俗又大碗的这个低成本刻板印象
是喔
对对对
怎么会讲出这个
他说现在是一个
高效能成本的状态
那伟创今天一样
跟這個紅海有點像
都是拉了一個底部出來
那只不過尾創要稍微強一點點
因為它在季線之上
那目前這個紅海今天原本有站上
後面有點上影線
那尾創接下來明天要挑戰的呢
就是這個平台的高點
哇 這個平台也很大一個耶
而且也很近
會不會要很需要努力啊
看起來這個量能跟這邊的量比起來
確實是比較大一點點
對 所以看明天能不能就一口氣站上
那即便開高走低我覺得也可以接受
因為可能要消化一下
那目前這個型態
小底部就確立站為全部均線
而且你可以注意到
我們大盤是彎這樣
對
所以偽創就長這樣
那是因為它前面就先這樣
對 它一方面長得少
一方面跌下來也跌得少
對 所以我會說的就是
目前來說伺服器代工廠
確實相對的波動會比較小
而且比較沒有所謂的套牢賣牙
沒錯 因為可能大家的關注度
也不在這裡
對啊 那如果能夠底部有一個粗量
我覺得後面要延續性
當大家市場又回來看這個的時候
我覺得延續性應該就可以拉出來
對 所以目前來說
你现在大盘可能行情不太好
那你又手痒痒的
那你买ABF又不知道要不要追
那我觉得有一部分的一个族群呢
是相对的抗争能力不错的
那就是这个
我们刚刚提到的这个大族群
好 这是伪创的部分
这我们看到就是音乐
我觉得他已经有点委屈
就他还把平台跌破了
对 没错
他之前就是
这一波急涨
没错 这一波急涨
因为那个时候是CPU的利多
然后CPU利多
炒完了一波之后
就开始在这边做盘证
那這一根呢
原本那一天是漲停板 爆大量
因為它的公布的營收
哇 是一個歷史新高
對 就是這天啊
沒有 這個是
7月公布6月的
這個時候是
我記得是公布5月的
然後呢 整個營收是非常好的
可是呢 開高之後
來到這個平台區
然後就又被開高手提
然後隔天黑黑
然後隔天就破底
然後就又一路下來
所以目前來說
以音業打的型態上來講
我覺得它跟鴻海廣達
跟鸿海还有伟创来讲的话
它这边还缺乏一个小平台的确立
因为它那个平台还没有站上
那当然全部均线月线也还没有站上
所以形态上稍微落后一点点
那音乐达的整个的营收的占比来讲
也是传统的伺服器的业务比较高
对它就是
所以这波CPU它才会是一码当千长
因为CPU是比较后段的
就比较稍微落后一点点的
那音乐达的份额是比较多的
那目前看起来我觉得音乐达的形态上
还要再稍微努力一下
不过基本面确实有努力的转好
是看得出来的
如果营收创高
而股价涨这样
真的叫做跌出价值来吧
是的
但这个就要有点耐心
因为它股价波动
哪时候才会有那一段
其实真的你回推看一年
可能就这一次而已
很多伺服器在工厂就涨这段
然后等到那个黄爸爸飞走就下去了
没错
所以它可能也是需要一个时间点的刺激
那不然的话
可能平常的时间大概就涨这样子
你跌你也不会怕
但你涨你也没什么兴趣
然后又等一个形态上的转强
好再来另外一位呢
就是品牌厂的华硕
华硕跟红K的走势
在近期有稍微拉开一点点
因为目前华硕的走势是比较强的
那有取得回答相关的
这一个Vera Rubin的伺服器的认证
然后也获得了相关的CSP
跟超级算力中心的大单
所以它基本面是确实还不错
确实是真的不错
那目前来说
这一个红K呢
在昨天也出现了一个
新高高前高
新低高前低的N字型的走势
那今天呢继续续电高
尾盘都一样
有些卖压都被卖下来
所以我觉得还好
那接下来要挑战上去的呢
就是这个压力平台
这个高点的位置
所以我们就关注一下
这边能不能是
延续性的这样缓步的电高
因为斜率比较缓一点
所以它涨的其实不会很快
那相对的跌就也不会很快
你看我们上礼拜大跌
它其实基本上算没跌
对所以也是一个抗震能力
相对不错的一档个股
好真的叫做先跌的
可能这段时间反而都非常抗震
是的
体质也好啦
体质是好的啦
最后一个呢
则是维星
它长得很不合群
没错
好奇妙
不过说实话
在这AI
所谓的那个NB代工
组装等等的里面
它是真的是
前面红利都没有吃到的
反而现在强起来了
对啊
它原本也都没什么长
你如果把形态
拉开一点来看
其实大概就在这个区间内
就乖乖的
目前来说呢
今天这跟红K
有一点这个突出
真的耶
對 你看它
我們剛剛看到的是什麼
在回季線
鴻海在挑戰季線
因為維新人家是季線在跟收盤價
所以它的走勢是相對非常扛的
你看那一天大跌
它也是直接拉長的下影線
然後就是在平台的低點
直接強拉一根下影線
那今天行情比較好了
它就直接做了一個平台的壓力區突破
這個大箱形整理是多方獲勝
所以維新目前的形態
先不要說什麼底部再轉牆
它是高檔震盪后突破
然后是强势股
对 所以微星这一根
中场收涨6%
我觉得是一个非常不错
然后出量去破坏大箱形争力
所以我觉得后面应该还有一些
可以值得关注的位置
这个是微星的部分
应该是最强势的
差异这么大
有一些是因为它已经在底部了
所以看起来很抗震
这个是强势股
我反而觉得强势股
在这段时间要特别留意
因为代表现在他一定有他自己独门的利多
没错
才会涨上去
如果需要今天节目所有的图卡资料的话
欢迎订阅一下我们的赵华爱伦说YouTube频道
都会把资料免费放在这个所谓的首页贴文栏
下一段节目我们有一个大来宾
是大家熟悉的面孔
他今天也有带来一个独家
他每一天盘前做功课的日志
这个也会在我们的贴文栏送给大家
这个日志很重要
因為填完之後
他就知道今天的盤怎麼走
以及今天有很多的
回後買上漲
歡迎回到趙華
歡迎說
好 今天的大來賓
每一次來
其實都會創造
非常好的收視率跟流量
是
而且他是我們兩個的啟蒙恩師
雖然他沒有想承認這件事情
但是他就是
有啦 後來有一次
這位來賓有承認說
突然有一次
你是他的大弟子
開心了一下子
對
其實他可能只是
講講
場面話
住口
我們先來歡迎他出場
就是我們的
K線之聲朱家弘 朱老師
嗨 大家好
最近股市的震盪比較大
沒錯
所以如果短線上
大家覺得有挫折的朋友
真的要學一下
朱老師的精神
對不對
谷海是一个长远的路
对
所以今天很特别
朱老师要独家来教一个
其实几年前
他有在我们的单元
叫表股在线等
有提供过
就是有一个所谓的叫战日志
每天要写一下做功课
这个很基本
那今天有很多是回后买
也有一些是抢反弹的
到底该怎么做
形态就要看起来
好 高手
怎么养成
朱老师盘前的必做功课
我们来告诉大家有一张表格
好 这个是我当初
开始学技术分析的时候
那学完了之后
每天就
这个都是我自己设计的
就是我每天根据我学的东西
认为你应该每天要看的一些资料
那大部分人就去看资料
可是我就把它做成一个表格
那强迫自己去写
你看完可能就忘了
那寫的話最後還有一個最重要
會有一個綜合研判
這就是練習把資料轉換成
對大盤的
我們台股大盤的看法
那經過很長一段時間的練習
你就會培養對大盤的盤感
熱騰騰的
今天早上盤前剛寫好的日子
長這個樣子
一般來說我們9點開盤
如果你早上8點半
你把整個的資料看一下
那最主要因為
美股要早上才能看那你如果前天晚上有空那你這些可以前天晚上先寫包括那我就來舉一個範例
那這個寫的日誌是來判斷
今天的大盤
寫完是可以判斷的
對 所以這是昨天大盤收完牌
你就把所有的資料寫一下
它是漲 然後漲了多少點
漲幅是多少
這個你都給它稍微的寫完
那寫完了之後
當然我這邊有列兩個指標
因為我們技術分析裡面
也會學指標
那這個指標也會讓你做研判
我們的大盤
目前是一個多空
還是一個短線的低檔的反彈
這個都可以在指標上看得出來
那早期我比較有空
最近因為實在很忙了
那我都會有做棋子當沖
所以這個是給做棋子
當創人去填的
棋子 這邊有個棋子
如果你要做棋子
因為這兩張圖是不一樣的
數字也不一樣
所以你做棋子就去填這個位置
那我先講一下
那邊有個大事記
大事記要記什麼
大事記就是今天有發生
跟股票有關的一些新聞
比如說前一陣子說
這個零股要改變
這個時間什麼都要改變
那你這邊可以寫一下
這個國家的政策
每一要開戰
對 每一開戰
或者是聯準會要升息
那這些我們都知道很重要
甚至於台積電的法說會
你也可以寫今天是法說會
然後它的大致上的重點
這個就是屬於大事記
那這是便於你以後回頭來查
回頭來查資料
好 那在這邊我們先講
這幾個板塊
那这一块包括到合计
到合计
那这个三大法人的买卖超
投信外资自营商
所以你很清楚地看到
昨天外资是卖超的
但是金额很少
为什么要你每天写
因为你每天写才知道它的变化
如果你一个礼拜再写一下
说不定昨天是大买的
你都不知道
所以我们要每天写
那我们就知道
昨天是合計是買超162億
是
所以另外也知道
外資好像沒有賣那麼兇
對 賣比較少了
前面都是幾百億
還有上千億賣的
不過昨天大漲他還賣
也可以知道這件事
OK 至少我們也知道
投信還有自營商都買
我們的類資都買
好 那下面就是融資融卷的變化
這很重要
所以我們又可以看到
昨天好像融資又增加了不少
74億
是 還好 因為這邊大漲
對
所以這個也是每天寫
你就會知道融資一路增加
或者減少
最後當然這個叫做融券
跟融券一二
昨天漲也有一些融券的增加
這一塊就是這個
三大法人的期貨單
他們的期貨單
從這邊可以看
自营商手上留的是多单
这是当天的多空单的增减
那投信多单有7万5千多口
那当然外资从8万多
现在减到7万8
那其实从这里看一下
我们的内资加起来
也是8万多口
对不对
所以看起来外资你会很害怕
哇七八万口
不會啊
因為我們的內資也有7萬口
所以這個可以平衡一下
不要說你只看一方面
就像我們的買賣超一樣
你光看外資會嚇死了
可是你看內資也都在買
表示內資在互盤
這裡有個五大交易人
跟十大交易人的期貨單
還有五大特定法人
十大特定法人的期貨單
這是全市場留的期貨單
全市場
那這個是要看它是一路增加了
還是我們的流倉去減少
那這些資料因為軟體不一樣
還有券商的軟體不同
那如果觀眾想要去做的話
有可能有些資料你找不到
那你就問你的營業員
因為券商營業員最清楚嗎
我們家的軟體哪個在哪里
當然三大法人
期交所每天都一定會固定公布
還蠻好找
差不多都有
這些期交所都可以找到
好 那這一塊就是美股
對 因為美股到底還是現在
影響全世界的
所以我們就看到
昨天的美股四大指數都漲了
尤其費半
費半漲了5%
这个蛮多的
当然这个表格是我个人用的
那也是很久以前
十几年前
那现在可能每个同学或者朋友
你可以增加你想要知道的
你想说那我再增加一行什么
台积电的ADR也可以
你每天就可以看台积电ADR是涨是跌
那这些资料你每天看完了
其实最重要就是培养这个
你要做一个研判
我们看到那么多数据
到底今天大盘好还是不好
好 这在风险就写下来了
对 写什么
这个就是最重要
美股四大指数都上涨
那台股昨天是诚心转折
我们台股昨天也是反弹
那今天美股又大涨
所以基本上
那昨天又一样说
今天只要放量续反弹
但是向上了有个月线压力
所以我們的月限大概是45,378
所以各位可以看一下
我們今天盤中的高點
就談到這裡
45,378
45,373,378
就談到這裡
這就是我們先判好
也就是說我知道今天會漲
但是到這裡你不要追
你不要開高跑這邊來追
那這邊就是壓
這個就是你每天寫
你對盤感事先就有掌握了
你也知道今天還會漲
昨天是反彈
那今天會漲
那如果我們再延伸一下
那大家可以練習一下
今天晚上你再把這些資料寫一寫
不一樣喔 每天都會變的喔
對不對
才要寫嘛
對 不能偷懶
你叫別人寫
最後別人是高手
你還是不會
因為寫的人話每天
我記得華爾街有一個超版高手
就是超黑版出來的
是 好
那大家如果有订阅我们
赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
刚刚那一张
我们会在首页的贴文栏
也会放在那边让大家做下载
好的 好 载起来
好 有新人嘛
你自然就会去做了
那我刚刚有讲
你甚至于还可以增加
自己想要知道的栏位
那这样子
我想三个月以后
你就会有感觉了
有感觉了
当然你要练到很熟
可能就继续选嘛 继续选
好 那我们刚才的这个
对大盘的研判就在这个地方
第一个它昨天是一个诚心转折
那昨天这边是黄金交叉
MACD已经接近零轴了
在长期多头里面接近零轴
是很容易反弹的
它这段很容易就会反弹
所以我们都是根据技术分析
去做今天的研判
所以今天就剛好碰到月線就下來
那同樣的
大家也練習一下
研判一下明天
朱老師不知道現在先跟我們講明天
因為外資還沒有
沒有 因為
美股還沒有開
還有一些數字可能還沒有出來
所以你要晚上再去把它查一查
再來做一些研判
但是最重要一個叫趨勢
所以我剛剛有寫叫反彈
反彈預壓是很容易反應的
跟多頭不一樣
多頭間壓不是壓
它很容易過
但空頭間壓你就要小心
它經常都會有壓力
這就是你慢慢的做
寫久了你就會懂了
好 所以今天真的反彈到
月線遇到一個壓力
對
好 所以有驗證
早上朱老師的判斷對不對
好 然後當然做完結論
我們要鎖骨
我們看到大盤可能是有壓力
可是肋骨怎麼鎖呢
對
這個其實是
這個才是我怎麼講
散戶要把股票做好
這個要做好
是
那我一直跟大家講
我們散戶的資源比較少
雖然我們剛剛去把一些資訊都知道
但這些資訊都公開的
大家都知道的
對不對
但是最重要就是要選到好股票
那怎麼樣選
我們最簡單的方法
就是在收盤前
原則上如果你能看盤
收盤錢
對 因為有些人可能沒辦法看盤
如果你可以看盤的話
12點鐘你就開始
去看盤裡面的強勢股
那什麼叫強勢股
就是漲幅的排行榜
都漲停啊 朱老師
對 就從漲停排
到9% 到8% 到7%
那就看當天的強弱
其實我們那天大碟
漲停的只有幾家
其他都很少
不是每天 因為今天很強
剛好遇到反彈
所以很多
這個強述股的排名有幾個重點
第一個 你當然這裡面的股票
一定要多投的股票
因為有很多是反彈
對啊 空投反彈
所以你不要看到漲停
它是反彈
所以第一個它要多投股票
那第二個 這些多投股票
你抓下來了以後就要看位置了
如果它剛好已經漲三四天了
那你就等它拉回
這個就是不要追高
意思就是不要追高
但它卻是很好的股票
因為它大盤還是空頭
它居然多頭還漲到高點
那表示這個很強
那你就把它留下來
那如果還有一個是底部剛剛反轉
我今天看到紅K
哇 多頭確認了
而且均線也做好
那我們就去鎖股
那這個鎖股有的時候會稍微等一等
比如說均線還沒做好
但它是多頭
那我們就擺在邊上
所以你如果自己會找股票
基本上
你有時候會找到底部
轉強的股票
那在這個檯面上
可能還沒有人去談它
對不對
因為很多股票
都底部偷偷的在漲
對不對
沒錯
對 但是你已經知道了
你就可以鎖它了
等到哪一天它轉強
你就可以开始操作
那第三个这个叫做
空头转强叫破切
长期都空头
但是比如说我们这几天
有很多涨停板的
那你看它有没有破切
有破切又是原来有题材的类股
那表示这里它可能要开始翻转
因为它已经跌够了
我们刚才有讲很多股票
都跌了1%了
对 500都跌到200了
那這時候如果有大量紅可以這樣破切
你也可以追蹤
不過這個可能是擺在最後
因為它還要做底你可能擺在最後那你每天去看這裡面都會有符合這些的股票那你找出來的以後這個就建一個鎖股的資料夾
然後你去稍微的排序
因為有的是這個
有的剛好回檔
也許明天就可以買了
所以你排序一下
你準備要買的股票
可能明後天要發動的
你就擺在最前面
然後這樣
另外你再篩選一下
比如說我講這個破切
可能還要一段時間
你暫時也可以不要拉進來
這些比較優先的擺在前面
那第三個重點
不要抱太多的鎖股
你不要鎖五六十檔
你鎖五六十檔
到時候你就很難覺得
我到底要買哪一支
所以你鎖完那股票以後
請你自己覺得哪個最強
比如說哪個題材
現在要發酵的
或者業績很好的
那你就大概把它精選
那原則上我建議大家
不要超過20檔
不要超過20檔也不少
手上15檔到20檔
因為有的要等嘛
還要回來嘛
你大概
然後你就專心
在你鎖的股裡面等機會
是
你不要再看別的了
你手上已經是很好的股票了
你手上的股票
有兩三檔讓你一直做
你的获利就已经很好了
这个就是我们要把精神集中
在现在的强势股
另外你每天看这个强势股
还有一个好处
你会发现本来很弱的
天天跌的股票
比如说我们讲被动元件
今天怎么都涨停板
这个股好像又要复活了
因为你看就知道
这个也是被动
哇 那这个又可以了
对不对
这个就是你在强势股里面看
是不是有同一个性质的股票
出现了很多党
那表示它转强
好 因为大家可能想要的
还是这种已经有回过了
对不对
或者是已经在比较低位阶的
所以这边的话
锁股名单列出来
我们就把今天收盘的强势股
那我刚刚讲12点看
你有一個準備盤前
如果剛好今天發動
那你盤前1點 1點20
你就可以進場了
你說收盤前就進場了
因為你12點就在找這些
那12點為什麼不能去進
因為12點還沒有收盤
你排漲停板的
可能12點半就下來了
它打開了
所以你大概先挑
這幾個都今天回後買上漲
那你就等
等到1點 1點10分
還是沒有下來 還是很好
那之後你就可以進場
不過這邊的話
觀眾朋友常常問這個問題
就說朱老師我等著等著
就要12點以後漲停了
早知道我就之前先買
那個是高手不拍
那個以後有空再來講
大家還是遵循這件事
這邊很多供應電腦的化漢
這個偽創今天漲停版
精采是強勢股
南亞中美金華碩
這邊有很多股票
有個觀念
如果你到1.20
漲停的就不要買了
就算了
我剛剛有講
你10幾檔股票
你不要每支都做
這裡沒有漲停的
漲6%的 漲5%的
像藍牙今天就是
今天就買點了
今天
對啊
那你不是1.20就可以買了嗎
是
對啊 你找到了 一支
這些有些你要等什麼
還要等盤整突破
還要等明天
這是昨天發動
對 有的還要等拉回
還要確認
對 你就把它擺在手上
你沒有等到的你就等
那假如你是收盤以後才看
那你就可以看明天會不會漲的
明天會漲的你就開盤就鎖著它
是 好 那我們這邊趕快來舉例了
大家一定很想知道
最好鎖了誰 鎖誰
對嗎
華碩昨天是多頭確認
昨天它漲的一定在強勢股
因為它昨天漲的好像七八趴
所以它在強勢股
這隻怎麼變多了
你看前面900跌到600了
昨天要找到華碩沒有那麼簡單
因為昨天有75檔漲停的樣子
不會 它也在
因為它只留一點點的上去
它也漲很多
對 它昨天漲很多
OK啦
所以你會找到它
那如果你是在昨天收盤前就看到了
那你买今天 OK啦
今天已经开始获利了
那你做隔日冲就卖
你要做波段你就沿着五军报嘛
你就沿着五军 对不对
就很操作很简单
好 那我们刚刚讲伪创
伪创这支股票
昨天你如果有看到的话
它昨天是多头
还真没想到
这也是昨天多头
看到没有
可是昨天多头不能做
因為它在月線下
它不符合我們做
這個在月線上
要在月線上
對 這個可以
這個在月線季線上
那這個昨天是不可以做
因為它在月線下 季線下
可是你可以鎖它
你一鎖你今天就發現
開盤就上均線
那就表示很強
它一開盤就跑到均線上
而且它的季線月線都向上了
它沒有向下
所以開盤你鎖著
如果它往上
你一樣今天就不會等漲停板
你就買到了
可是今天如果我還是遵守在這個
所謂收盤前
它就已經漲頭了
那你就要做剛才
我們所沒有漲停的股票
一樣嘛
所以基本上
你如果沒有做它
你可以留在手上
我剛才講不要忘了
這個明天再漲
後天就做拉回
下次拉回就是你的股票
就是一支很好的股票
其實這支股票明天才是關鍵
怎麼說
這個壓力要過
來到壓力區了
明天一過
回後你就買
就很有把握了
它已經連山紅了
又有放量
那就表示這個底是真的是底
不是假的
這些底都沒有量
所以你在這裡買很容易失敗的
這個以後慢慢分享
下次来讲一下量
对 量价的关系
好 因为刚刚我们讲了很多
好多官人朋友也会有一个误解
他都会说跌了
现在上涨不就叫做回后买上涨吗
事实上朱老师的名言
不只朱老师用
好多人在用
好多人在用的话
我们一定要让官人朋友知道
回后买上涨是有定义的
对 正确版本
不是跌了上涨
就叫回后买上涨
它有一定的条件
所以任何时候你要买股票
都要把條件先列出來
也就是我們所謂的檢查一下
那回後買上漲
第一個多頭回嘛
就是回檔
所以多頭回檔的時候
一定要記得
什麼叫回後買上漲
第一個沒有破前面的低點
它並沒有把
我回檔的時候
沒有把前面這個低點跌破
這是最重要的
一跌破你就不能買了
你買幾乎都會賠錢的
好 那第二個
还不要跌破月线
在月线上
因为月线会给你支撑
你买了就容易涨
那第三个
出现大量红K的上涨
所以这个是重点
你要买上涨
回后买上涨
那很多人说跌三天可不可以买
他就买回后
跌五天又在问
老师可不可以买
还没有上涨
所以回后买上涨
这个上涨就是红K
那它要什麼條件
它要突破五日均線
它要上漲站上五日均線
還要過昨天的最高點
這個都在幫助你
買了不容易停損
容易成功
這也代表它轉強了
我又可以站上五均
又把昨天的高點突破
因為昨天的高點是壓力
為什麼不然昨天為什麼不漲
為什麼在這裡你就下來了
所以那個是壓力
這些條件都符合
就是最好的買的位置
所以第一個要多頭
每次上漲
我們剛才講
你不是強勢股選了一支股票嗎
它漲三四天
那你就等回
然後不要破前提
然後紅K上漲
這個叫回後買上
那如果是底部追蹤的股票
往往一支股票
你大概有兩或三次的機會
做到回後買上漲
就是有一波 兩波 三波
那如果你三波都能夠把握
隨便加一加也十幾% 二十%
這個獲利很高的
很多人回後買上漲
會誤解說那就是100%要賺錢
但是它還是有一些機率
可能會失敗
所以出場點 停損點要放在哪裡
好 很簡單
回後買上漲
你買就設好停損
你有兩種方法
一個用固定停損
就是5%
我們如果固定停損
100塊跌破95那你就要賣
那如果沒有停損
那就恭喜了
你就開始了
就像這個華碩
剛才華碩第二天了
那你就沿著五軍座
那這是做短線
像我們剛才有大盤的日志
你就知道大盤線在反彈
所以你做股票不要做長線
你就做短線
要不然大盤又殺下去
你的股票長線也賺不到錢
所以你掌握好你自己的方法
然后按照纪律去做
你久了久了
你就会掌握这个获利的方法了
好 这边的话也帮大家举例
这一看就是强势股
如果它都已经涨了好几波
我还能做吗
这个是跳风涨停
所以当天你在强势股就看到它
会看到它 不是今天看到
前面就看到了 跳风涨停
如果你在这边锁
回後買上漲
這個回檔 回後買上漲
現在回檔 昨天是回後買上漲
你這幾波都有賺
只是有時候賺多 有時候賺少
好 那藍亞呢
你如果在前面
這也叫強勢股 對不對
這也是漲停板
那你就鎖 回來了
回後買上漲
然後跌破五均賣
今天回後買上漲
所以藍亞科
如果你今天
蓝牙
如果你前面就锁住的
我刚讲你会有一波两波
好几波可以做
那你今天收盘前
哎呦 他又来了
因为在你的20档里面
你20档就有他
那你自然今天就是好的进场位置
好 看起来画得都好容易
进场 进场 进场
可是我们好像都是追高追高追高
杀低杀低杀低
那个是我们人性
都喜欢追高杀低
但是你稍微的克制一下
因为你要在股市赚钱
你总要有一些
这些忍耐的地方
所以忍耐是我们成功操板走
一个最重要的一个特质
你一定要能够忍耐
不要去追考就好
今天很谢谢朱老师
朱老师其实是我们的常课
那每一次教学都还是有新的体悟
因为像最近在反弹
大家可能就要辨别
到底是空头反弹
還是真的恢復多頭的格局
這些都延續性
後面的延續性都很值得大家來做推敲的
對
好 那大家如果想要日志的話
就是把趙華愛人說的YouTuber
訂閱起來
因為其實我們那時候還在做